je crois que c'est à la mode en cette
rentrée scolaire c'est tout ce qui fait
rêver les enfants à savoir les couleurs
le fluo en particulier les couleurs
écossaise centre est à la mode
actuellement mais tout ce qui est très
américain également elle est énormément
aux jeunes ça les fait rêver tant dans
ses oasis n'est demandé le retrait
pastels très rose très bleu ciel c'est
sous peu nous sinon cette année pour lui
donner un nouveau look c'est hollywood
chewing gum pour les teenagers c'est
pierrot l'offre pour les lignes de
produits plus romandie c'est la panthère
rose qui fait un très beau come backs
est en ce moment en europe bref
américain encore et toujours au rayon
vêtements cette fois où l'on retrouve la
même ligne de démarcation entre
classique et fantaisie pour les garçons
à ce titre
inspiré des universités américaines
pour les filles
s'ils peuvent ils tuent dans un lot
bcbg et puis on n'a pas oublié non plus
les teenagers mais juste 16 ans dans un
style branché